wenn die gute alte Kartoffelsuppe ist in
unsere schlagzeilenschaft dann waren die
klimakaoten von letzte Generation am
Werk sie sehen es hier die haben gestern
wieder in Potsdam zugeschlagen dass
jüngste Opfer ein Claude Monet ja und
auch heute sind wieder Proteste geplant
und zwar hier am Potsdamer Platz in
Berlin und da vor Ort ist unser Kollege
Karl Victor Wachs was ist denn da los
was machen die da wir sehen schon
Polizei im Hintergrund
ja felizo ist es also hier geht's
richtig ab die sind hier festgeklebt das
könnt Ihr sehen
die Autos kommen nicht durch Polizei ist
in Masse vor Ort ich frage jetzt einmal
hier was die Menschen die sich hier
festgeklebt haben so beschäftigt hallo
kann ich sie kurz fragen
hallo warum kleben sie denn hier
wir haben jetzt diesen Sommer schon
gesehen dass der Rhein ausgetrocknet ist
wir haben Brände den Leuten in
Brandenburg ist in die Häuser
abgefackelt unsere Nahrungsmittel gehen
auf den Feldern zugrunde und was macht
die Regierung sie ist nicht mal bereit
100 km/h Tempolimit auf Autobahnen
einzufügen entschuldigen sie ganz kurz
die ganzen Leute da die jetzt nicht zur
Arbeit können ist ihnen völlig egal das
ist uns tatsächlich überhaupt nicht egal
wir stören die Leute hier schon und ja
wir werden jetzt da jemand sitzt im
Krankenhaus im Krankenwagen der ins
Krankenhaus muss und jetzt nicht schafft
ihretwegen was sagen sie denen vorne sie
noch nicht da waren ist ein Krankenwagen
durchgefahren den haben wir
durchgelassen dann haben sich also hier
abgemacht oder wie
die Menschen die nicht geklebt waren
haben den Krankenwagen durchgelassen
naja also Valentina Feli wir sehen hier
ist durchaus eine angespannte Situation
die Polizei ist mit vielen Leuten vor
Ort es gibt auch noch zahlreiche
Pressesprecher und Unterstützer der
klimakaoten die hier stehen die
sozusagen von der Seite den Kraft zu
sprechen dass sie sich eben nicht
abmachen lassen und damit zurück zu euch
ins Studio
Viktor wie viele Leute sind da ungefähr
vor Ort jetzt da am Potsdamer Platz und
vor allem wie lange planen die
klimaextremisten da noch auf der Straße
zu sitzen
der mir vorhin gesagt Sie wollen hier so
lange sitzen wie es nötig ist das heißt
eventuell auch den ganzen Tag hier waren
vorhin extrem viele Leute jetzt hat sich
etwas ausgedünnt weil die Schaulustigen
keine Lust mehr haben die guten
Herrschaften kleben ihn nämlich schon
seit zwei Stunden hier sind das haben
wir vorhin schon gesehen hier sind die
ganzen Unterstützer die also den von der
Seite Mut zu sprechen und außerdem
ungefähr 12 Beamte mit vier Einsatz
wegen von der Polizei aber Viktor
versuchen die Beamten denn überhaupt die
Kleber zu entfernen werden da
irgendwelche Anstalten gemacht oder
lässt man sie da jetzt einfach erstmal
sitzen
bisher lässt man sie da einfach sitzen
vorhin wurden hier einige Leute
festgenommen die an der Seite randaliert
haben und die mit Bannern gewählt haben
an Orten die ihn nicht zugewiesen wurden
und dann haben die Protestler mir gesagt
dass ihnen anscheinend dieser Ort
zugewiesen wurde was das genau bedeutet
müssen wir jetzt noch mal klären und vor
allen Dingen auch wann diese Leute da
mit chemikal mit mit chemischen Mitteln
abgemacht werden Viktor Dankeschön du
für den Moment du wirst das natürlich
weiter beobachten ich bin gespannt wie
lange die Klima Kleber da den Verkehr
noch aufhalten wunderschön da freut man
sich immer im Berufsverkehr ja muss ich
sagen das geht ja die letzten Wochen
permanent in Berlin
halt mehr leider wir haben es ja schon
angekündigt wir waren jetzt auch in
Potsdam und sie schlagen ja inzwischen
auch bei Gemälden zu die mehrere
hunderttausend Euro wert sind und
eigentlich mit dem Klima ja auch nicht
wirklich viel zu tun haben
hier landet wieder Suppe auf einem 110
Millionen Euro teuren Gemälde von Claude
Monet das Kunstwerk zum Glück mit einer
Glasscheibe geschützt die Botschaft der
klimakaoten Menschen hungern Mensch
frieren Menschen sterben wir sind in
einer
Klimakatastrophe für die interessieren
sich die anderen Besucher der
Ausstellung aber eher wenig auch der
Sicherheitsbeamte scheint nur mäßig
beeindruckt von der Aktion dieser beiden
das sind sie die ökoextremisten nach der
Aktion in Polizeigewahrsam
Kartoffelsuppe für Monet für van Gogh
gab es vergangene Woche Tomatensuppe
zwei anti-öl-aktivisten hatten das
berühmte Gemälde Sonnenblumen mit zwei
Dosen Tomaten beworfen neben der Frage
der Sinnhaftigkeit dieser Aktionen steht
vor allem die Frage im Raum wie die
Chaoten ihre Behälter mit Wurf Essen in
die Museen schmuggeln können doch nicht
nur Kunst muss dran glauben auch Autos
erst in der vergangenen Woche hatten
andere Chaoten der selbst ernannten
Klimaschützer bei VW für eine nun ja
spektakuläre Aktion gesorgt in der
Wolfsburger Autostadt hatten sie sich am
Boden des Porsche Showrooms festgeklebt
VW reagierte gelassen vor abends die
Haustechnik runter Licht und Heizung aus
Energiesparen im autopavillon sollte ja
eigentlich den Idealen der extinction
Rebellion entsprechen aber protestieren
im Dunkeln macht wohl einfach nicht so
viel Spaß für VW läuft die Aktion noch
glimpflich ab im Vergleich zu dieser
französischen Automesse in Paris bei
Ferrari kleben sich die französischen
chaotenkollegen nämlich direkt an den
Fahrzeugen fest singen Auto-Show der
Zerstörung ja mit Zerstörung müssen die
sicher auskennen
[Musik]